are you feeling okay [ __ ] it's your
boy psycho [ __ ] rap oh yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] we are trying to join the Dark
Brotherhood okay okay shut wait where
the [ __ ] am I mine went home yet I guess
not there we go so apparently you can
start it by going to win Hell you come
here where you're not wanted these are
foods you pollute our city with their
stink and you refuse to help the strong
folks here's that bench because ok hand
map map so you have to go to like the
end
CN where's the inner this place so then
I lace rocks this isn't it it's no
secret the Archie we've some ritual
trying to call the dark brotherhood but
who's going to stop him me I'll have no
heart attack ok here we go talk to her
event authority now
thank you do that and my way
so he's in there
that mare right sorry over here here we
go whatever you want to say that event
is RT now I'm doing it perfect I can
selling candy from a stillborn baby
sighs employment here you come at last I
knew you would what the [ __ ] it worked I
know you didn't come I just know it I
did the black sacrament over and over
with the body in the things and then you
came in a fasten from the start
Brotherhood ah yes of course so long so
very long but now that you're here you
can accept my contract my mother is she
she died I I'm alone now so they sent me
to a terrible orphanage and arrest him
on her Hall mistress is an evil cruel
woman they call a crow of the kind but
she's not kind she terrible to all of us
I ran away and came home and perform the
black sacrament now you're here and you
could kill drawn behind hello Callie
okay Constance the show she really is
kind okay
and I think if I got a dad you got it
down yes
grip that ripped it there we go let's
give this patch okay i'm less countless
match
at my wife s
I wonder Nick introduced as a month what
is their music text should not say
mirror back that those who shirk their
duties will get an extra beating do I
make myself clear yes yes ground and one
more thing I will hear no more talk of
adoptions none of you with crap is
getting adopted ever nobody needs you
nobody wants you mm-hmm want to kill
grillin when aventis escape really got
meaner than ever I really thought she's
already kill one of us I guess my get it
laughs we're saying yay yeah I'll say I
can't dad I finish that quest will be
tech know
dash kappa and I look up I guess okay
hey ma I wait now I have to go out
laughter pop it knows that we love cat
yeah here I used to be in it thank you
and I cook an arrow into me okay well
well had the kind is she you know haha I
know you could do it I can do it I knew
that Brotherhood would save me here just
like I promised this should set you a
nice price thank you thank you again
perfect